muriel un bon soir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
après la première vague en avril dernier
tout le monde a salué la bonne gestion
de la pandémie l'état hébreu avec des
restrictions forte notamment pourtant
aujourd'hui israël est le pays qui
compte le plus de contamination sur les
deux dernières semaines alors comment
est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'avec un départ
total d'israël a confiné très rapidement
fermé ses frontières a confié 13 mois a
été très efficace
après on a eu du poids de l'économie
puisque vous savez c'est toujours un
échange entre la santé et l'économie
mais j'ai connu ça veut dire quoi parce
qu'on est passé en israël vous preniez
c'était un pays qui n'avait que 4 % de
chaumont on est passé brutalement à 20%
qui dit chômage en israël le filet
social est beaucoup moins généreux quand
en france à partir de là ça génère une
certaine pauvreté et nous gouvernement
avait avait confiné peut-être un peu
trop vite et c'est ce qu'il reconnaît
maintenant pour permettre aux gens de
retourner travailler
alors justement sa réalité économique ce
nouveau confinement est ce qu'il est
source de divisions au sein de la
population est ce que le sujet s'invite
dans le débat politique
d'abord le de confinement et un certain
nombre de deux entreprises peut-être
continuer à travailler les entreprises
qui sont le télétravail est bien entendu
recommandé un certain nombre
d'entreprises de moins de 12 personnes
peuvent travailler en de manière
séquentielle
c'est à dire un certain nombre de
travailleurs et en suit en faisant les
gestes barrière en aménageant des trois
savent bien entendu on va évidemment il
ya une certaine tension puisqu'il ya
certains groupes qui refusent ce
confinement et là on parle
essentiellement de deux groupes
je ne veux pas dire les religions parce
que le monde religieux des parements de
vos chaînes et à l'intérieur du monde
lui il ya des gens qui respecte
complètement avec des rabbins qui vit à
l'heure à leurs oreilles en effet vous
devez respecter les consignes
et entre autres le ministre de
l'intérieur qui fait partie d'un
mouvement
la parti religieux lui est resté au
gouvernement en disant à son parti en
effet le soutenons la politique du
gouvernement de nous soutenons cette
action de confinement les gestes
barrières pour ce qu'ils peuvent sortir
donc ça c'est quelque chose de très
clair il ya une fraction du monde
religieux la conduite d'un deux c'est
bien ce temps cela communauté une phrase
qui ont défait la tête n'adhère pas à
ces mesures avait pas d'autres
contaminations genre les pourtant ils
ont payé un prix parce que parmi le
nombre de décès il faut savoir qu'ils
seraient là quand même même si en ce
moment il a un taux de contamination
important a comme un ado de décès fait
c'est toujours trop j'ai appris quelques
m17 quelque chose qu'on aurait voulu
éviter bien entendu mais on est
pratiquement 10 millions d'habitants en
israël et il ya 1500 11 décès avait
pleuré à ce jeu est ce que la situation
est hors de contrôle aujourd'hui la
situation sanitaire est ce que les
hôpitaux sont débordés comment est-ce
que ça se passe depuis tous ne sont pas
débordés
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux commencent à en
effet être plein sur le plan sur dans
les usines ou vers les départements
peuvent ils sont en train de rouvrir
d'autres départements c'est-à-dire de
créer des espaces donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui sonne se fermer pour le moment
aujourd'hui les des hôpitaux ne sont pas
débordés
il sort à la nuit de leurs de ce qu'ils
peuvent prendre et c'est pour ça que
entre autres avec les deux mains il ya
des nouvelles structures de santé alors
renegade jules coordinateur de la lutte
contre le colis 19 a présenté ses
excuses pour n'avoir pu empêcher un
confinement à ce qu'il est le seul
responsable selon vous vous savez que ça
ne peut jamais être un homme qui est
responsable il ya eu une enquête traîne
intéressante il 52% de la population va
dans cet échantillon a dit que la
population était responsable 48% a dit
que c'était le gouvernement mais 52% a
reconnu sa propre responsabilité je
pense que c'est très intéressant parce
que finalement les mesures barrières on
parlait de la communauté ultra-orthodoxe
tout à l'heure mais dans la population
générale est ce que les gens ont du mal
fini finalement à respecter des gestes
barrières non les gens mais des masques
et des gens en effet même dans les
manifestations ou respecté les distances
ça c'est des filles qui espère il ya une
autre
un autre communauté où il ya aussi des
clusters c'est en effet dans la
population arabe israélienne est donc à
ce niveau là mais les verts ont souvent
étaient contents qu'on leur démontre
qu'on leur impose un certain nombre de
mesures de confinement
parce que ça va être celle ça les a
aussi aidé les faire passer dans leurs
populations et ça c'est quelque chose de
très important
merci beaucoup allez-y juillet allez-y
oui il n'ya eu quand même une très bonne
coopération entre médecins israël et un
médecin palestinien les médecins
parisiens et même de gaza étant venus se
faire former soit au point de passage
d'erez soit à l'hôpital à beersheva
quand même des très bonnes nouvelles
merci beaucoup muriel avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de la fondation france israël